my name is fritz I'm Stephen and work ap
burg together we're the coke and mentos
guys we drop Mentos mint candies into
bottles of coke zero you may have seen
our Bellagio fountain video and it's
like 100 and something million people
have seen that we're going to show you
how you can drop Mentos mint candies the
bottles of coke hero and make geyser of
soda we have a piece of PVC just a PVC
tube right here on top is a PVC cap that
you get it the regular hardware store
and then we've drilled out a regular
bottle cap off of a soda bottle so that
there's a whole the passes all the way
through there but that gives us the
threads of a soda bottle to thread onto
the top so we take this this tube and we
put in one two three or five six Mentos
six Mentos is plenty and then we take a
pin we've got two little pin holes on
the sides of this it goes like that and
that holds the Mentos inside the tube so
that when we screw it on top of a bottle
it waits there till we're ready to set
it off so all you need to do is pull the
pin out this incredible nucleation
reaction happens inside the bottle
releases all the carbon dioxide comes
flying out the bottle important things
to remember warm soda warm soda most
important if the soda is like out of the
refrigerator you'll get a geyser about
this tall you can get nozzles just like
this at you p / calm so you can you can
as well roll a little piece of paper up
into a tube put a card over the the
amount of it and do a similar kind of
thing but the advantage that you get
with this kind of nozzle is that you can
make different effects so we have a
half-inch hole we have a quarter inch
hole we have three holes in a row or a
slot all these different cuts make
different effects and give you guys errs
that go higher guys going to go in
different directions
do your own choreographer so if you want
you can get yourself a whole pile of
these and do your own blasio time and if
you do send us the video cuz we're dying
to see it come on quiet settle